[Música]
pintara eso para mí es esa llamarse a
que hace mi cuerpo lentamente hacia la
mortalidad yo la coreografía en esta
pieza y hago el paralelo con el
personaje del poema que es un hombre de
marcha que camina en la nieve hacia su
propia mortalidad hay algo que a mí me
gusta de esta idea de invierno y de un
hombre que camina solo por días y días y
días
en la nieve hasta el momento que
descubre su mortalidad esta imagen
también me gusta mucho porque bailar
como solista hay algo de esto también
que es monótono que es repetitivo pero
que uno lo hace porque está en servicio
al otro día yo quiero seguir bailando
con la vejez con él con el cuerpo que yo
tengo hoy con el cuerpo que tendré
mañana porque creo que hay
si hay una luz que ayuna para que haya
un espacio disponible a través del
sufrimiento físico o atrás de los
obstáculos físicos y yo creo que la
danza hoy que yo presento es mucho más
íntima y mucha más acción por tanto y
quizás mucho más
a personal de lo que yo hacía antes
a causa de esto a causa del instrumento
que comienza poco a poco a decaer
[Música]